[MUSIC PLAYING]
JON SKEET: Welcome
to Hadley Freeman,
author of "Life Moves Pretty
Fast" and various other things.
So a very warm welcome to you.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Thank you.
JON SKEET: It seems we're
in a room, at least,
with people who haven't
read the book yet.
So I wonder if you
could just start
by giving us a brief
precis of what it's about
and why you've written it.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Right.
So this book, which I wrote
about almost three years ago
now, is about '80s movies,
which I love very deeply.
And it's not just
a nostalgia fest.
Because, obviously, you can
turn on Channel 5 any night
and see loads of utterly
random talking heads just going
"Oh, yeah, "Mannequin"
is amazing."
"Oh, yeah, "Back to
the Future" is amazing.
Like, obviously
those are all true.
Although I might
actually quibble
with the "Mannequin"
thing there.
But what I wanted
to write about is
how these movies,
from the '80s movies,
these movies from the
'80s, teach us lessons
that we don't get today.
And that is because actually
Hollywood was weirdly very
liberal in the
'80s and they were
able to do really interesting
things with movies
that we don't get today.
So for example,
depicting abortion
on screen in a positive
light, or having a black actor
take a role that was
written for a white actor,
and all sorts of
things like that.
Depictions of
masculinity, movies
made about and just for
women, all those things
were coming out of the
'80s, and we don't really
get those anymore.
JON SKEET: OK.
So that's sort of
why you wrote it.
One of the things that strikes
me most when reading it
is just how much fun it
seemed that you were having.
HADLEY FREEMAN: So much fun.
JON SKEET: Was that
genuinely real,
or are you just really
skillful at writing
as if it were that much fun?
HADLEY FREEMAN: Well, there was
a lot of angsting beforehand,
once I had this idea, because
my publishers were really
not into it.
They just thought nobody
buys books about movies,
which I quibble with.
Almost all my bookshelves are
filled with books about movies.
And "Hm, '80s movies,
a bit passe now.
Does anybody really
care about that?"
And I just knew they did.
I knew they did.
All my friends love '80s movies.
I love '80s movies.
And I very much
live by the maxim,
"You should write
about what you're
interested in, not trying to
guess what other people are
interested in."
Which sometimes doesn't
always work probably readers
would say from "The Guardian."
But I believe if someone is
passionate about their subject,
that really comes through.
And so I angsted a lot about
how am I going to do this?
And I thought, "How do
I sell this to people?"
And then I just thought,
"Stop worrying about it.
Stop trying to convince
your publishers.
Just write the book
you want to write.
Write the book
you want to read."
Which is always what I
say to aspiring writers
when they ask how do
they find their voice
or what should they
be writing about.
I just say, "Write
what you want to read."
and I just thought, "I'm going
to write what I want to read."
And it was so much fun.
And the more I wrote
it, and the more I
spoke to friends about it,
and the more enthusiastic
I saw all my friends were
and my parents' friends were
and other, people getting
into it and saying,
"Oh my god, you've got to talk
about, obviously, the 10 best
montages, and you've got to do
the 10 greatest power ballads."
Everybody had all these
list ideas for me.
"And obviously
you're going to have
to include "The Lost Boys"
and the this and the that.
And thought, "Oh, wow,
people really are into this."
And then I suddenly got
a burst of confidence,
and then it was so
much fun to write.
JON SKEET: Well, I
think we can see,
even if it weren't for the book,
by "Stranger Things" and "Ready
Player One" there
is so much almost
pent up nostalgia for the '80s.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Yeah, and that
really wasn't around as much
when I was writing it.
Because I was
writing it in 2014.
JON SKEET: So you
created the environment.
HADLEY FREEMAN: I created it.
I think I'm part of it.
Which is, I don't mean like
I'm anywhere on the same level
as "Stranger Things,"
but I have this idea
that there's a 30
year rule, which
is that it takes
30 years for people
to look back on a
decade with nostalgia.
And that's because kids
who grew up in that decade
are now adults, and they're
now making the content,
and they're looking
back and going
"See, that was what was great."
And they're putting
it out there.
So I'm very much
of that generation
that is putting it out there.
JON SKEET: Cool.
So let's dive straight
into specific films
and specific messages that
you've taken out of them.
And I'm going to start with
"Ghostbusters," because I
watched it all last night.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Lucky you.
JON SKEET: I was meant
to writing a book,
and I thought, "Blow it.
I'm meeting Hadley.
I'm gonna watch "Ghostbusters."
HADLEY FREEMAN:
"Blow it" indeed.
JON SKEET: And it's
aged pretty well.
HADLEY FREEMAN: It's amazing.
JON SKEET: For the most part.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Yeah.
JON SKEET: So you bring you
know this is as almost male role
models of friendship.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Yeah, yeah.
JON SKEET: Obviously,
as soon as you
start talking about the
'80s "Ghostbusters,"
you think 2016 "Ghostbusters."
How would you compare
them in terms of,
does the reboot, whatever
you want to call it,
of "Ghostbusters" portray female
friendships in the same kind
of way, or is it more extreme?
I mean, the friendships
in original "Ghostbusters"
are reasonably extreme
and non-normal.
But there's a
certain truth there.
HADLEY FREEMAN: There is.
And also, obviously, part of
the charm of '80s "Ghostbusters"
is it was so based on their real
life friendship, particularly
Bill Murray and Dan
Aykroyd, who were friends
from "Saturday Night Live."
And in fact, Dan
Aykroyd originally
wrote "Ghostbusters" for
him and his best friend
John Belushi, who
died in the middle.
He wrote a line
in the script, he
got a phone call saying
that John Belushi had
overdosed in Beverly Hills.
So he was writing it
for the two of them,
and you can sense
that friendship
and how Ramis was a close
friend of theirs as well.
And I really feel you
can have that feeling
that these guys all know
each other, love each other,
and appreciate each
other's weirdness.
You know, they all called
Bill Murray the Murricane.
And obviously Harold Ramis
then made other movies,
and Dan Aykroyd made other
movies with Bill Murray.
Harold Ramis obviously
then made "Groundhog Day"
with Bill Murray.
And they had a very
complicated friendship.
They were all always
falling out with each other.
It was a very weird time to be
a very successful male comedian
in the '80s.
But I feel that
all comes across,
and you sense that,
despite the weirdness,
they all love each other truly.
And now, I had so much goodwill
towards the 2016 female
"Ghostbusters".
First of all, I love
the idea of women
carrying a great franchise.
I really love Paul
Feig, that he is the one
he's championing this idea.
He's the one who
directed it and I believe
wrote the screenplay for it.
I think Melissa McCarthy,
Kristen Wiig, all good things.
And it just completely didn't
work, which was disappointing.
It was a bit like watching
Hillary Clinton's presidency
bid.
It was just like, you
really want it to work,
and it just didn't work.
And I think so many of the
things that were wrong with it
exemplify what's wrong with
movies, this kind of big movies
today compared to the '80s.
I mean, for a start, it was
all filmed on a studio lot.
So the whole city looks
really anonymous and generic.
You don't really
get a sense of where
on earth these people are.
Whereas in the '80s
"Ghostbusters",
it's very much New York City.
Like, they are on
the New York streets.
They're going to
Tavern on the Green,
this restaurant in
Central Park, which
is where Rick Moranis
has his freak out when
he's turned into the ghoul.
You see the taxis going
around the corners,
the piles of garbage,
Larry King on TV,
and there is a
specificity about that--
obviously the New
York Public Library--
that is very charming.
And people then sense
that this is real.
This is real.
JON SKEET: I think it helps
if you've been to New York.
HADLEY FREEMAN: It
definitely helps.
And if you grew up
in New York as I did.
But I feel you're watching
this, you're like,
"OK, this is real."
I mean, I watched
"Ferris Bueller"
when I was like 8
when I first saw it.
And I'd never been to Chicago.
I didn't go to
Chicago until I was
an adult, which is
weird, because I only
lived in New York.
But I liked that they
were on the streets.
They were going to the museum.
They were going to restaurants.
I got a sense of Chicago.
It wasn't just some
generic studio lot
that could be used for
a sitcom the next day.
And there was no rough edges
to the 2016 "Ghostbusters".
I mean, Bill Murray, in the
original "Ghostbusters",
is really freaking weird.
I mean, he's giving
electric shocks
to this teenage
boy when it opens.
He's leching on everything.
He's basically stalking
Sigourney Weaver.
And the movie accepts all
that and isn't excusing it.
And in fact, she's making
fun of his face to it.
Whereas you don't
get that as much.
It felt more try
hard what they were
trying to do with
the characters there.
And I mean, first of
all, I really don't--
I think it's a mistake to try
to reboot such a beloved movie
as "Ghostbusters".
I mean even "Ghostbusters"
couldn't do it
in the '80s when they made
"Ghostbusters 2" and everyone
got cross about it.
So I don't really know
why you would do that.
Why not just make
your own new movie?
JON SKEET: Right.
Which, I guess,
at the same time,
we have if we're looking
for strong women leads etc,
we have "Wonder Woman."
HADLEY FREEMAN: Yeah.
Which although is
an old movie too.
I mean that is piggybacking
on another old franchise.
Which is fair.
Which is true.
But people will always
have sentimental feelings
about old movies.
I feel like that is the wrong
way to rehash '80s movies.
The right way is to do something
like "Stranger Things,"
which kind of digests
all these '80s movies
and makes something
totally new through them,
without then having people
my age and older being like
"Oh, it's not as good
as the original,"
because it is original.
It's just doing all
these amazing homages
to "Stand by Me" and "Alien"
and all this cool stuff.
JON SKEET: So that brings
me to TV in general.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Mm-hm.
JON SKEET: You go in
detail in the book
into the economics
of why films aren't
made in the same way, why
things like "Dirty Dancing"
just wouldn't get made now.
HADLEY FREEMAN: At all.
JON SKEET: But it feels to
me like interesting things
are happening on TV.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Definitely.
I mean, that is where
things are happening now.
And I don't necessarily
think that's a bad thing.
I do think you lose something
from not having that big "go
to the cinema" moment.
I know I sound like I'm
sitting in my rocking chair
on a porch talking
about this, but you
know, I remember the week
"Batman" came out in 1989
and going to the movie
theater with my dad,
and it was such a huge deal.
I mean, probably you guys
all weren't even alive then,
but it was such a big
deal when this came out.
This movie had been
building up all summer.
You go to the cinema, there's
all these Batman logos,
insignia everywhere.
And obviously at the
time, grown-ups are like,
"Oh, this is disgusting.
It's so commercial."
For a kid, this
is amazing, and it
felt like a really
collective experience,
sitting in the cinema, watching
Tim Burton's Gotham City,
seeing Jack Nicholson.
It was amazing.
And you don't have quite that
same feeling watching something
on TV.
You just don't.
And it's not even about "Ooh,
the glory of the cinema."
It's more that everybody's
watching things
at different times now.
And it's more of an
individual experience
rather than a
collective experience.
JON SKEET: I guess I think about
when "Handmaid's Tale" was on.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Yeah.
JON SKEET: I would
watch it without being
able to breathe barely
until the adverts
and then suddenly check Twitter.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Check
Twitter and see everything.
JON SKEET: So there's a sort
of different collectivism.
HADLEY FREEMAN: It's a
different collective experience.
It is.
Judd Apatow talks
very sentimentally--
I think in the book I
used the quote where
he talks about going to the
"Ghostbusters" when that
opened, going to the
"Ghostbusters" movie
and standing in the
line around the block.
And yes, this does
sound like we're all
talking about going to drive-ins
in the 1950s or something.
But there is something
to gain from that,
and there is something else to
be gained from watching things
on TV and tweeting about
it with your friends
and seeing what Armando Iannucci
is saying about something
that you just watched and
other people who you like,
Sharon Horrigan or whoever.
But I think there is something
sad about the slow death
of big cinema, really, because
that is what I grew up with.
JON SKEET: Yeah,
I think it will be
interesting to see what happens
to cinema in the next 10,
20 years.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Yeah.
JON SKEET: With more
and more great stuff
going on TV, basically.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Yeah,
which they're not even
trying to compete with,
because they're too scared
to compete with it, really.
JON SKEET: And
occasionally cinemas
will show TV series
at the cinema.
This is a strange,
strange situation.
Going back to the lessons that
we should have been learning,
the title is "The Lessons
We Learned" as if "Job done.
We don't need to talk
about those things.
We've learned."
Now, I'm pretty
sure you'll agree
that a lot of those
lessons haven't
been learned completely.
HADLEY FREEMAN:
No, that's right.
JON SKEET: Is there
any one in particular
that you think we really need?
Is there one of these films
that you should say "Right,
this should be on
the curriculum.
Everyone should just
get the message"?
HADLEY FREEMAN: I mean, I,
as a woman and feminist,
all the rest of it, I mean,
I would say "Dirty Dancing."
Really, I do think "Dirty
Dancing" is an amazing movie.
And people, particularly, not
wanting to gender stereotype
here, particularly men tend to
laugh at me when I say that.
I have yet to meet a man who
has ever seen "Dirty Dancing"
willingly and not been forced
by his girlfriend or wife.
JON SKEET: You
absolutely have now.
HADLEY FREEMAN: This is
why I come to Google.
Everything is here.
But it is an incredible movie.
It's a movie about the
importance of legal abortion,
which is what Eleanor
Bergstein, the screenwriter,
wrote it to be.
She felt in the '80s that women
were taking feminism and access
to abortion for granted and that
Roe v. Wade was under threat.
And so she wanted to write
a movie for teenagers that
stressed the importance of it.
And so she took this
movie, set it in,
I believe it's the
end of the '50s.
It's the '60s, isn't it?
No, it must be the '50s,
where abortion was still
illegal in America.
And there's a character in the
movie who gets pregnant and has
to have an illegal
abortion and then
has to be saved
by Jennifer Gray,
a character called Baby,
Jennifer Gray's dad,
who's a doctor.
And this is really just
slid into the movie.
I mean, obviously when people
think of "Dirty Dancing,"
they think of Patrick
Swayze holding up
Jennifer Gray in the
lake, and the two of them
having sex, and all the cool
songs on the soundtrack.
I mean, and that is what
you're supposed to see.
But she buried
this subplot in it
and made it so essential to the
movie that no one could take it
out.
And the studio made it.
The producers at first didn't
have any problem with it,
and then a pimple cream
wanted to sponsor the movie,
and they saw it, and they
were like, "Oh, we can't
have this abortion thing."
And Eleanor Bergstein was
like, "Oh, what a shame.
Because the movie
kind of hangs on it.
It can't really
work without it."
And they were like, "OK, fine."
And in the end, the
movie made so much money
that obviously it didn't
matter that it wasn't
sponsored by a pimple cream.
And the really sad
thing is, recently
some Hollywood producers went
back to Eleanor and said,
we'd love to remake "Dirty
Dancing," obviously.
And she was like, "Great."
And they said, "But
we're going to take out
the abortion thing."
And she said, "No way."
And what she did instead was,
she rewrote it for the stage.
And you guys might
have seen this
in the West End, the "Dirty
Dancing" musical which she did.
And she oomphed up
the abortion subplot
and emphasized about
how the doctor really
could have gone to prison
for helping a woman who'd
had an illegal
abortion and was dying
on a table from
internal bleeding
and really made it very
central in the play.
I mean, you can't
ignore it in the play.
In a way, in the movie, you
could almost overlook it.
In the play, you really can't.
And that movie has made almost
a billion around the world.
Which just emphasizes, how
cowardly and wrong Hollywood
movies are now.
I mean, you try to think of
a movie that depicts abortion
now.
OK, so the obvious
one would be "Juno."
That was made, came
out about 10 years ago
now, in which abortion
is depicted unbelievably
negatively.
So negatively, even though
this is a schoolgirl--
I think she's like
15 in the movie--
who is not in a relationship
and needs to do something
when she's pregnant.
And she goes to the
abortion clinic.
It's dirty.
It's seedy.
The woman at the reception
desk is licking this lollipop
in a salacious way.
And in the end,
the character Juno,
who's played by Ellen
Page, of course,
is persuaded not
to have an abortion
because an abortion protester
tells her outside "You know
your baby has fingernails."
Now, there are a lot
of reasons a woman can
choose not to have an abortion.
I mean, I have two
children myself,
so obviously there was
a period in my life
when I chose not to
have an abortion.
I'm not saying every woman
who's pregnant should
have an abortion.
But you cannot have an abortion
protester use a stupid argument
like that and on screen
show that as that's OK.
That's not OK.
Particularly since
the movie was written
by a self-professed feminist,
Diablo Cody, and stars
one, Ellen Page.
And I find it really upsetting
that at no point in this
did they think this is
not right to do this.
JON SKEET: And I
know you interviewed
Ellen Page about that.
Did you also
interview the writer?
HADLEY FREEMAN: Diablo.
JON SKEET: Why she chose
to write it that way?
HADLEY FREEMAN: Yeah, I did.
I did interview her,
and I said to her,
"I don't understand why you
depicted abortion so negatively
in this movie.
You could have just had
her say, 'Do you know what?
I actually want to have this
baby and give it to a couple
who don't have a baby.'
That's a perfectly
reasonable reason
not to have an abortion."
And she said to
me, "Any woman who
doesn't think I'm not
doing enough for feminism
can kiss my butt."
I mean, that is not a response.
That is not a response.
JON SKEET: It's whataboutism.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Yeah,
that's just not a response.
That's a stupid response.
And then "Knocked Up"
was the other obvious one
in which a woman gets
pregnant on a one night stand.
She's 22, just got her
dream job being a TV host,
and she rejects flat out
not having an abortion.
Which is fine.
Maybe a lot of
women would do that.
It seems unlikely
in that circumstance
that a woman in LA who
just got her dream job
would reject having
an abortion, but fine.
And the only character
who mentions it to her
is her mother.
And the mother is styled in the
movie as basically horrendous.
And the mother
says to her, "Just
get it taken care of and one
day you'll have a real baby."
Now, obviously that's a
terrible way to put it.
That's a terrible way.
And nobody who is pro-choice
as I am would say it like that.
Just say, "It's your choice.
It doesn't matter.
It's your life."
JON SKEET: I'll
support you either way.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Do you want
to be looking after a baby?
Just say, "Do you want
to have a baby right now?
You're 22.
You don't even know
this guy's name.
Like, seriously, do you
want to have a baby?"
If she goes, "Yes,
I do, actually.
It feels important to
me," then you say fine.
What you don't say is,
"Just get rid of it.
It's disgusting.
It's not a real baby anyway."
That's not the way people
talk about abortion.
JON SKEET: So
between "Juno," we've
got a pro-life campaigner
who's giving bad reasons.
And then we have a
pro-choice person
who's giving bad reasons.
It feels like we need a
more mature representation,
basically.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Yeah,
there's positive way.
And there's only
been one movie that's
really dealt with it, which
was a small independent movie
called "Obvious
Child," which came out,
I think, in 2016, starring the
very excellent Jenny Slate.
Which is about a girl who gets
pregnant-- well, not a girl.
She's in her 20s.
A woman who gets pregnant
after a one night stand.
But the thing is,
the whole movie
is about her decision whether
or not to have an abortion.
And they then show her,
the camera's over her.
She's on the gurney.
She sighs too, and there's
tears rolling down her face.
And you think, sure, some women
really do feel this very strong
way about it, but for a lot
of women now, they don't.
They don't.
I mean, I had an
abortion when I was 24.
I'm very happy to talk about it.
And it was just a relief.
And everybody in here
will know somebody,
whether they know
it or not, who has
had an abortion at this point.
It doesn't have to be
depicted as this seismic thing
in someone's life.
It is just something that
happens, and you deal with it.
Whereas in '80s movies,
you have something
like "Fame," which
everyone forgets
had an abortion in it, in
which a girl in the school
gets pregnant and she's
white and he's black.
Already you cannot imagine this
happening in a movie today.
And she just goes to
the clinic, it's done,
and then she goes
back to the school.
"Fast Times in Ridgemont
High," 1980, I believe,
Amy Heckerling, written
by 18-year-old Cameron
Crowe, a 14-year-old played
by Jennifer Jason Leigh
gets pregnant.
She gets taken to the
clinic by her older brother,
played by the much loved and
much missed Judge Reinhold.
He picks her up afterwards.
They go home.
She goes back to school.
I mean, these are just
making abortion part
of life, which is
what it is now,
rather than making it either
a big deal or a terrible deal.
JON SKEET: And do
you think that it
was acceptable to do that in
the '80s because society was
different, because people
weren't paying attention
to what was going
on in the films,
or just because
Hollywood was bolder?
HADLEY FREEMAN: Well,
two things, really.
I think people weren't
paying as much attention.
I think also movies
were able to be riskier.
Those movies that I
mentioned, "Fame,"
"Fast Times at Ridgemont
High," "Dirty Dancing,"
were all made fairly cheaply.
They were seen as
mid-range movies.
So they weren't required to make
a billion dollars back right
away.
Which is what movies now are.
Movies are now marketed
around the world.
It costs a billion dollars to
market movie around the world.
So every movie that comes
out that gets a big release
like that has to be
basically "Transformers"
or something that doesn't need
a lot of translation, that
isn't going to upset
people in China, which
is a massive market
now, and isn't
going to upset the
Christian right in America.
So things are much blander.
Everything specific
is taken out.
Everything real is taken out.
And that's why movies
today feel very bleached.
JON SKEET: And is that
just Hollywood, or is it
the global film industry?
HADLEY FREEMAN: It's
mainly Hollywood.
It's mainly Hollywood.
Because it's mainly
Hollywood movies
that get to go around the world.
I mean, the French film industry
doesn't spend a billion dollars
sending movies around
the world, generally.
But also, Hollywood
underestimates things a lot
of the time.
So Hollywood is now--
in the '80s, a movie
made 80% of its money
in America, 20% overseas.
And now that's flipped around.
And in some ways, you
could say that's good,
that Hollywood is aware that
the rest the world exists.
But it does mean that they
have these weird assumptions
about what people in
China like to watch.
So they'll say, "Well,
in China, they're not
going to go see a movie
with a female lead,
or they're not going
to have a movie
with a woman on the poster."
There are loads of
examples online.
You can look at it through a
website called Google of which
movies that had female women--
female women-- had
female actors or women
on the posters in
America and Britain
that have men on
the poster in China.
They do this also with
black and white actors.
So like "12 Years a
Slave," for example,
had Brad Pitt on the poster
when it went overseas.
I mean, there's a lot of that.
But actually, if you look at
the Chinese film industry,
a lot of their movies
do have female leads.
They do take much
riskier things.
It's just that America
is just like, "Whoa,
we can't annoy the Chinese.
We have to be really
careful with this."
JON SKEET: So is "Black
Panther" out in China
yet and what are
they doing with it?
HADLEY FREEMAN: It'd be
really interesting to know
what happens with "Black
Panther," because actually
the last movie that made a
lot of money overseas that
had an all black cast was
"Coming to America" in 1989.
It would be amazing if "Black
Panther" can kind of restart
that again 30 years later.
JON SKEET: So I wasn't sure
whether we should discuss this.
Two white people talking about
racism is never a great look,
but just briefly, in the book
you talked about Spike Lee
and Eddie Murphy having
very different ways
of empowering African-Americans,
different ideologies about it
almost.
Whether you make films that are
about black communities or you
have black people in
white communities.
Eddie Murphy in several films
may be the only black actor.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Yeah.
JON SKEET: And it
struck me thinking
through that argument
how "Hamilton"
has done something interesting
to take a third position there.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Yeah, right.
Yeah.
JON SKEET: Do you
think that's something
that works to compromise
on those two positions,
or is it just, would either
Spike Lee or Eddie Murphy
be happy with what's
happened there,
or do you think they still
have an issue around it?
HADLEY FREEMAN: I don't
think Eddie Murphy
is that happy about anything
these days, which kind of
breaks my heart, because he
really is my favorite of all
the '80s actors.
But I think Spike Lee would kind
of love it, surely, "Hamilton."
I mean, I hope most of
you have seen "Hamilton."
It is amazing as you watch it.
When you first see
it, you're just like,
"Whoa, Thomas Jefferson
is a black guy."
And then you literally
don't even see it
like within five seconds.
It's amazing.
JON SKEET: In fact, I'd
say almost goes in reverse.
So in fact, I bought
this copy of the book
on my way to see
Hamilton in December.
And then, in February, I went
to Hamilton Grange in New York
and saw various pictures of
Hamilton and Jefferson and all
these people and I thought,
"Wow, they're white."
HADLEY FREEMAN: Yeah,
they're all white.
JON SKEET: It was really weird.
HADLEY FREEMAN: All white.
That's true.
And you suddenly think back
on other plays and movies
you've seen.
You're like, "That's so weird.
Everyone was white in them.
That's such a weird
casting decision."
Anyway, anyway, so Eddie
Murphy's whole thing was
he was going to infiltrate
the mainstream Hollywood
industry in a way that no black
actor had been able to before,
and Richard Pryor had been
too self-destructive to do
so before, and then
make movies from within,
and kind of recreate
the system from within.
Which he successfully,
incredibly successfully, did.
And it's a testament to his
talent that he did that.
Because a black actor famously
needs to be like 10 times more
talented than a white
actor to get a role,
and he was a million times
more talented than everyone,
and he was the most successful
actor of the decade.
Whereas Spike Lee
was all about giving
a voice to the black community
and what the black community
was going through at the
time, so making things
like "She's Gotta Have It"
and those kinds of movies.
And they were absolutely
polar opposites.
And Eddie Murphy, as
the decade went on,
got increasingly attacked for
this by the black community,
feeling that he'd
abandoned them,
that he was making
"Beverly Hills
Cop" and "The Golden Child,"
in which he's basically
the only black guy
in it and making
movies for white audiences
and not reflecting
the black experience.
And he became more
and more embittered
and drew grew more
and more into himself.
And then he made
"Coming to America,"
which is an incredible movie
in that it has an entirely
black cast and no
white audiences
seemed to notice
that in America.
And if any of you know
anything about racial history
in America, that really
is kind of a miracle.
And then after that, he
started doing more of that.
So like "Boomerang" he
did in the '90s, in which
he sort of launched Chris Rock.
But he became
angrier and sadder.
And anyone who has the kind of
success that he did so quickly,
it's going to screw
up your brain.
And Spike Lee, I mean, I think
Spike Lee is just incredible.
I mean, his movies
from the '80s and '90s
are some of my favorite.
But he found himself being
painted into this tiny corner
that he couldn't
really break out of.
But if you look
at the early '90s,
there were so many amazing
movies about African-Americans,
particularly people
like John Singleton
and "Boyz n the Hood,"
stuff like that, that you
don't see anymore today.
And I personally believe
that it was the combination
of Eddie Murphy and
Spike Lee together
that helped that era of the
'90s movies of African cinema.
JON SKEET: Cool.
Thank you.
Let's take away from politics
entirely for just briefly.
One of the things
I love that you say
is that the "Princess
Bride," which
is one of my
favorite films ever,
works brilliantly because
it is a fairy tale,
and it's a spoof
of a fairy tale.
Much like "Into the
Woods" is a spoof
of a fairy tale as a musical,
and an absolutely awesome
musical.
And various films
have tried to do this.
And some succeed and
some really don't.
So for me, ones that
succeed, "The Frighteners"
is a great sort of horror
film and spoof horror film.
And "Starship Troopers"
manages to work
in various different ways.
I remember I was at university
when "Starship Troopers" came
out, and I was in
the fourth year
and had various friends
in the first year.
And "Titanic" was out at
roughly the same place.
And all of my first year friends
said "Oh, I love 'Titanic.'
It's so deep.
No pun intended.
But 'Starship Troopers' is
just mindless violence."
And all my fourth year
friends were going, "Wow,
'Starship Troopers'
is very, very cunning.
'Titanic' is extremely dreary."
HADLEY FREEMAN: Yes, yes.
That's true.
JON SKEET: It worked for me.
And then you've got
films like "Scary Movie"
which are very explicitly
trying to be a spoof.
And again, for me,
it doesn't work.
HADLEY FREEMAN: No.
JON SKEET: What do you
think is the key to getting
that balance?
HADLEY FREEMAN: I feel
that the filmmaker
has to really love the genre.
I mean, another one I would
add into that that's quite
like that is "Mars Attacks."
And I know people have mixed
feelings about "Mars Attacks."
I am a big Tim Burton
fan, as you might
have guessed at this point.
And I feel like you
get that he really
loves that genre of that kind of
schlocky alien movie, obviously
Ed Wood, the whole thing.
Like, he loves "Plan 9."
And he's sending that
up but also doing it.
And with the "Princess
Bride," William Goldman,
who wrote the original book,
which I highly recommend
if any of you haven't read it--
It's so amazing-- obviously knew
those books from reading them
to his daughters at night.
I mean, he said he
wrote "The Princess
Bride" because his daughters
loved princesses and brides,
and they loved books about them,
and he just combined the two.
And he knows those
stories, and he also
knows those kinds of pretentious
academic approaches to them,
which is what he makes
fun of in the book.
A little bit like "Possession"
by AS Byatt as well.
They're making fun of this
kind of academic attitude
towards literature,
which is what he does.
You have to love the genre.
You can't hate it.
And I feel like the scary
movie genre, the "Scary Movie"
movies--
does that make sense?--
they're just hating on it.
They're just making fun of it.
And you have to
have love for it.
And I don't mean to keep
mentioning this TV show,
with "Stranger Things,"
you feel the love.
JON SKEET: Right,
oh, absolutely.
HADLEY FREEMAN:
It's not just making
fun of '80s hairstyles
and '80s music.
Normal homages to '80s stuff
just take the silly surface.
You have to have
a deeper feeling.
And with "Princess Bride,"
you get the deeper feeling.
It's not just like, "Oh,
princesses screaming
in a tower and dragons."
No, there is deeper
emotions going on.
JON SKEET: Fantastic.
Yes.
Back to the politics side.
So I was thrilled.
I started reading the
book thinking, "Hey, this
is a book about movies."
And then thought, "Hey,
it's another feminist book.
Hurray!"
I just finished a bunch
of feminist books.
Life moves pretty fast.
It's another.
Yay.
And you have the Magnolia Test.
Before I go further, do you want
to describe the Magnolia Test?
HADLEY FREEMAN: Oh my gosh.
No, you describe the
Magnolia Test, actually.
You'll do it better
than me if you read--
JON SKEET: Oh, it's so long
since I wrote the question,
but it's about a strong
woman-led film that depicts
women doing awesome
things and tends to have--
and this is the bit that
I want to talk about--
men who are really not much.
We'll say, either they're
explicitly despicable
or they're just a bit useless.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Yes.
JON SKEET: Do you
have any good examples
for allies and just men who
want to be decent human beings?
HADLEY FREEMAN: Oh,
for sure, for sure.
JON SKEET: Of strong
women-led films
that depict men not
in a romantic role
but being decent human beings?
HADLEY FREEMAN:
Yes, so obviously
the Magnolia Test is, as
I'm sure you've all guessed,
named for "Steel Magnolias,"
which is my favorite women's
movie of all time.
And any man who's
like, "Ew, I don't
want to see a movie about lots
of old women," you're so wrong.
It's one of the funniest
movies ever written.
JON SKEET: It's the one of
these that I haven't seen yet.
HADLEY FREEMAN: I mean,
again, like "Dirty Dancing,"
no man has ever willingly
watched "Steel Magnolias."
It was written by a
man, I should add,
and it's a true story
about his sister.
Anyway, that's a
whole other issue.
My favorite movie that depicts
platonic male-female friendship
is "Say Anything."
I'm amazed by how few people
in this country have seen it.
In America, it's such
a major teen movie.
It's up there with "Dirty
Dancing" or whatever,
or "Breakfast Club."
"Say Anything" is so great.
So how many have seen it?
Most of you probably haven't.
Just a few?
Oh my god.
All of you guys need to go home.
Not just guys.
Guys, girls, everyone, just
go and watch it right now.
I excuse you from
work for the day.
So it's about John Cusack.
JON SKEET: Oh, it's
John Cusack as well?
HADLEY FREEMAN: Do you not know?
Oh my god.
It's John Cusack at
his most John Cusacky.
It's his ultimate role.
Forget about "Grosse Point
Blank" and "Grifters."
It's the ultimate Cusack role.
He's like the weird kid in
high school, wears a trench
coat and stuff.
And he's in love with Ione Sky,
who's the class princess, who's
very beautiful.
And her father is played by John
Mahoney, the recently deceased
father of Frasier, as you all
probably better know him as,
who is wonderful in it.
So it's about John Cusack
trying to get with Ione Skye.
But in the background, he's
got his two best female friends
called DC and Corey, one of whom
is played by the immense Lili
Taylor, who is amazing.
And you're watching this
movie, and the opening scene
is them talking.
And the three of them obviously
have an incredibly close
friendship.
They're very similar.
They totally get each other.
They get each other's music.
They go shopping for guitars
together and everything.
And you're watching this movie
and thinking, "Surely, he's
just going to get with
one of them in the end.
He's going to forget
about this princess."
But no.
No.
They just want him to
be happy, and he just
loves hanging out with them.
Because as the movie shows,
his male friends at school,
one of whom is played
by Jeremy Piven,
are just total idiots,
played by Jeremy Piven.
Let's just reiterate that.
Who are just total jerks.
And he gets his most fun
with his female friends.
And it's a wonderful depiction
of male-female friendship.
And I went to a coed
school for six form.
And I was like, "Yeah,
that is what it was like."
Not all men and women who get
on then have to sleep together.
JON SKEET: Right.
HADLEY FREEMAN: That's
a very nice message
to get from a movie.
JON SKEET: Yeah, absolutely.
And it's almost the anti-message
of "When Harry Met Sally."
HADLEY FREEMAN: I know, I know.
Although, I do feel like--
I mean, it's not
really, but it is true.
It is the anti-message of that.
But there is also the
cross-friendships there,
with Bruno Kirby
and Carrie Fisher.
They are all hanging
out, and they're not
all sleeping with each other.
It's not like some mass orgy.
JON SKEET: And anything that
has Carrie Fisher it just
gets my vote immediately.
HADLEY FREEMAN:
Exactly, exactly.
Good.
JON SKEET: Yeah, so sad.
OK, I have no idea
what the time is,
but it feels like we've
been chatting away.
HADLEY FREEMAN:
Sorry, I talk so much.
JON SKEET: No, no, no.
Quite the reverse.
It's extremely needy for me.
Other people may have questions,
and I'll just interject more.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: First, I wanted
to answer a comment.
You said that one day TV shows
will be shown in the cinema.
They are shown in the cinema.
For example, "Game of Thrones"
was shown in the cinema.
JON SKEET: Right.
AUDIENCE: Of course,
it must be a spectacle.
But politics and
all that stuff--
what do you think about
forcing diversity in cinema?
What do you think about
scandal in the Academy Awards
about not enough black
actors and all that?
What do you think about it?
What are your thoughts?
HADLEY FREEMAN: I mean, I
write about it quite a lot.
Because until The
Guardian stopped
being able to send me
to LA for the Oscars--
Very sad-- I used
to go to the Oscars
every year to write about it.
And of course I think
it's good for it
to be drawn to attention.
It's not like I think
there should be quotas,
but I do feel like the Academy
should be shamed into the fact
that so few black winners
of Academy Awards.
It is amazing.
So few women directors have
been nominated or won awards.
It's mortifying.
And this should be
drawn to attention.
And the problem is,
is that the Academy is
very largely old white men.
There are many
statistics about it.
And they just see themselves.
They look for themselves.
AUDIENCE: OK, but
what about there
are less black actors in work?
HADLEY FREEMAN: I mean, it's
never going to be 50-50,
but there obviously
should be more.
I mean, there have been
plenty of incidences
of African-American actors just
being completely overlooked.
I mean, Eddie Murphy?
How has Eddie Murphy
not won an Oscar?
I mean, he clearly should have
won an Oscar at this point.
AUDIENCE: What about the
same thing about DiCaprio?
HADLEY FREEMAN: About?
AUDIENCE: About
DiCaprio [INAUDIBLE]..
HADLEY FREEMAN: Well, he
did win his Oscar, though.
I mean, he got there.
I mean, I'm sorry.
I mean, I genuinely
believe Eddie Murphy is one
of the greatest actors around.
I mean, he got nominated
for "Dreamgirls."
I personally would
have nominated him
for "Bowfinger," which he is
incredible in, and all of you
need to see that too.
It's not an '80s movie.
It's a '90s movie,
him and Steve Martin.
I mean, Eddie Murphy's
performance in that
is just astonishing.
And as he said, I mean, you
can Google Eddie Murphy.
You can Google
"Eddie Murphy speech
at the Academy Awards."--
It's so hard not to do that--
in which he talked about this
in the '80s, saying, "Well,
you guys gave an award to
a black actor last year--
I can't remember who it was.
Maybe Denzel
Washington.-- so you
don't need to do it for
another 30 years, right?
And it's like, yeah, that
is literally how it works.
That is literally how.
You know, Greta Gerwig,
why is she now overlooked
for Best Director?
It's stuff like that.
You just think
this is ridiculous,
that it's these old white male
movies that win all the time.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Do you think Netflix and Amazon
getting into film production
is going to revive this kind of
'80s tradition of being a bit
edgier?
HADLEY FREEMAN: No question.
I hope so.
I mean, the film festivals
are really freaked out by it,
as far as I can tell.
A lot of them refuse to show
Netflix and Amazon Prime
productions.
Which is just ridiculous.
You can't fight against
what is happening.
I don't know how
Netflix and Amazon
Prime have so much money.
Probably you guys in this
room can enlighten me on that,
but they are making
really amazing stuff now.
I mean, the conversation I
hear with my friends, what
used to be like, "Are you going
to see something in the cinema
this weekend?"
It's now "Have you seen that
new Netflix documentary?"
I mean, that is how
people talk to each other.
That's how.
I've got two very
young children,
so I'm at home most evenings.
And my boyfriend
and I, all we do
now is watch stuff on
Netflix and Amazon Prime,
and stuff that they've
made, original content.
We're currently watching
"The Defiant Ones," which
is amazing, which is the
documentary about Jimmy
Iovine and Dr. Dre.
JON SKEET: I should've
been keeping a list.
I really should.
HADLEY FREEMAN: You know, this
is the stuff we watch now.
It's not going to the multiplex
on Friday night anymore.
The world has changed.
JON SKEET: But one interesting
thing, to come back to films,
I was thinking
about films that I
have found not necessarily
edgy, but have at least promoted
a more diverse worldview
and engaging young people
politically, I think, tend
to be around either superhero
or superhero-like.
Even if you didn't
like "Ghostbusters,"--
HADLEY FREEMAN: No, it's true.
No, it's true.
It's true.
JON SKEET: The remake
of "Ghostbusters,"
you can think it's
kind of superhero-ish.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Yeah, Yeah.
Absolutely.
No question.
JON SKEET: And by the time we've
got "Wonder Woman" and "Black
Panther" and at the same
time, young people certainly
in America and I
think over in the UK
as well to a slightly
lesser extent, appear
to be more politically aware.
HADLEY FREEMAN:
Yes, no question.
JON SKEET: Is there a
correlation, causation?
HADLEY FREEMAN: I
mean, it may be.
I mean, it's certainly
true that superhero movies
have been good at
smuggling in good roles
for women and ethnic minorities.
They have been good at that.
In "Ghostbusters," one
of the specific things
was to improve the
representation of--
this is a terrible
way of putting it--
the black Ghostbuster.
I mean, one of the big
faults with the original
"Ghostbusters" is how Ernie
Hudson is so sidelined in it,
like for no reason.
Either have a minute or don't.
And oh, god, Leslie, what
is her name who plays her
in the new "Ghostbusters"?
My mind's just gone blank.
Can someone google it for me?
Anyway, she has a
real role in it,
and she's in it the whole
movie, and she's not pushed out.
And that is great.
That was great.
And definitely young people--
I don't know if it's
because of superhero movies
that young people
are more in line.
I think young people
always need to go further
than the generation before.
And young people are going
further in this than we did.
JON SKEET: Right.
And another thing
I find interesting
about superhero films,
you talked about "Batman,"
even though it was dark in a
way, it had huge light moments.
HADLEY FREEMAN: What?
Tim Burton or?
JON SKEET: The Tim Burton.
HADLEY FREEMAN:
The Tim Burton one.
Yeah.
JON SKEET: So big Gothic
feeling, but still hugely funny
bits.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Yeah.
JON SKEET: And when you
wrote the book was before--
I think before "Deadpool."
HADLEY FREEMAN: Yes, it was.
JON SKEET: Definitely
before "Thor Ragnarok."
HADLEY FREEMAN:
Yeah, that's right.
JON SKEET: Do you
feel that things
are taking an upswing there?
HADLEY FREEMAN: I think so.
And it's weird.
I've seen actors
like Chris Pratt
or whoever get more in
these kind of roles.
And they are funny rather
than tortured Christian Bale
and tortured Tom Hardy
with the mask on his face.
I mean, I honestly--
do you guys all like those
movies, the modern Batman?
JON SKEET: I loved them,
but I didn't laugh at them.
Whereas we recently rewatched
"Ragnarok" and it's hilarious.
HADLEY FREEMAN: It's very funny.
It's very funny.
No, it's true.
I mean, I loved the modern
Christian Bale Batman
with the Joker.
I mean, that is a
great role, obviously,
with Heath Ledger as the Joker.
But it's not a fun watch.
I mean, it's quite heavy
weather, really, watching it.
And everything is so dark.
I mean, not just like mood.
I mean, the lighting, you
can't fricking see anything.
Whereas you watch Tim Burton,
I mean, it's so much fun.
And watching Jack Nicholson
do his little dance
down the steps
towards Kim Basinger,
he's playing Prince on
his boom box, so much fun.
And it looks like a cartoon.
It doesn't look like it's
taking itself so damn seriously.
And it doesn't have
the constant car
chases like you have with
the Christian Bale ones.
And the Christian
Bale Batmans, I
don't mean to keep
knocking them.
Obviously, they're
beautiful and they're
done in this amazing way.
Christopher Nolan is obviously
an incredible filmmaker.
But there is just too much.
There's just too much.
I feel there's too many
characters, too many people
being tortured,
emotionally tortured.
You know you have Gary Oldman.
You have Christian Bale.
You have whoever the villain is.
You have this and that.
JON SKEET: And it
became more so, I think.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Yeah.
JON SKEET: So by the time you
get to "Dark Knight Rises"--
HADLEY FREEMAN: Oh my god.
JON SKEET: It's really all
on for a very long time.
HADLEY FREEMAN: It's so long.
And like Avengers,
there's just too much.
They pack in so much
in these movies.
Whereas I feel like with
Tim Burton's "Batman,"
you have just nice, clean
Michael Keaton a bit unhappy
in a castle, some
villain, the end.
JON SKEET: There is the angst.
HADLEY FREEMAN:
Yeah, oh, there's
angst, but angst in a quite
interesting self-mocking way.
Like he knows he's
this pathetic rich boy.
Like, feel sorry
for me rich boy.
Whereas Christian Bale
is just miserable.
"This is a great night out."
JON SKEET: Do we have
any other questions
so I can be slightly
less self-indulgent?
AUDIENCE: I used to work
in children's publishing,
and I went once to a
marvelous showcase,
and I was really excited,
because I'm a big Marvel fan.
And I remember being incredibly
disappointed because they
had this huge cinema
screen, and they were
showing all their new films.
And then it came up in massive
letters "Everything we do
is to--" and I was just
really excited for it--
And it said "To
sell more product."
And I remember just thinking--
HADLEY FREEMAN: Whoa, yay!
AUDIENCE: --Is that what's
happening to cinema today
that they want to basically
make everything PG-12 so they
can appeal to as many
people as possible?
HADLEY FREEMAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And that's why
I think films like Batman
don't work anymore,
because they're darker
and they're older,
and everything
feels a little bit safer, and
we don't have many 18s anymore.
I remember when I used
to go to the cinema,
I used to sneak into
18s all the time.
And it's now like
there's no 18s.
Everything's really
dry, and everything
is trying to sell more
product and merchandise,
and I wondered if
you shared that.
HADLEY FREEMAN: I
mean, definitely
everything is trying
to sell merchandise,
but you have to blame
'80s movies for that.
I mean, it was the '80s movies
that really got onto that.
Obviously, "Star
Wars" in the '70s
and then "Batman" in the
'80s and "Ghostbusters".
But I don't feel like they
were just made for that.
They weren't seen as
vehicles for that.
It was the merchandise came off
the greatness of the movies.
And actually, the merchandise
just kind of took those movies
by surprise, I feel.
Whereas now the movie is
almost a sideshow to everything
around it.
There's just not as much effort
put into scripts anymore,
is, for me, the real
problem between movies
today and movies in the '80s.
And that's because so
much of a movie's takings
comes from overseas,
that they don't
want to have movies that
have complicated scripts that
need a lot of translation, where
things have cultural references
that won't translate overseas.
Which is why movies now, like,
for example the Christopher
Nolan Batmans are so full
of car chases and shootouts
and special effects.
Because obviously, you don't
need to translate those.
I mean, whereas you have
something like going back
to Tim Burton's Batmans, there's
a lot of dialogue going on
in those movies, whether
it's in the newspaper office
or whether it's
Bruce talking, having
the long conversations with his
butler and these weird parties
that he had.
There's emotional stuff
that needs translating.
And it's just too
much of a faff.
And like, why bother?
Big CGI effects
work well anywhere.
Although I personally find
them incredibly tedious.
One of the things I love
about "Ghostbusters"
is how charming the
special effects are.
They're so shonky.
And now when I see special
effects in a movie--
I went to see the
modern "Jungle Book,"
I'm watching the
actors thinking "I
know you're just standing
against a blue screen."
That's all that's
happening here.
You feel no real connection
between what's going on,
the actor and the special
effects, I don't think.
And I think that's
something that's been lost,
but that's what
translates overseas.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Do you also have lessons
that we shouldn't
have learned from '80s movies?
HADLEY FREEMAN: Oh my
goodness, of course.
So obviously '80s
movies, for all
I'm talking about
Eddie Murphy, etc, etc,
were completely, totally racist.
Which is why it's amazing
that Eddie Murphy was
such a success, which is another
reason why everyone should just
worship his talent.
If you look at--
I mean, let's see, what's
the worst '80s racist movies?
I mean, where to even begin?
Obviously, there's
"Sixteen Candles,"
which is John Hughes' first
film with Molly Ringwald, who's
upset because her parents have
forgotten her 16th birthday.
What an innocent sweet
movie, you might think.
Ah, but let me tell you about
their random Asian exchange
student called Long Duk
Dong, who just once had
sex with a white girl and does
things like fall out of trees
at inopportune moments.
There's also this
unbelievably weird bit
in "Sixteen Candles,"
where the boy who
Molly Ringwald's in
love with is talking
about how his girlfriend
has passed out at a party,
and he could have, quote,
unquote, "Had her five
times without her noticing,"
and then tells the school
nurse, who is played by
Anthony Michael Hall,
"Why don't you just go out in
the car and have sex with her?"
He doesn't say in those words.
He goes, "why don't
you go upstairs?"
And he does.
And then the girl wakes
up next to this dorky guy.
And she's like,
"Did we have sex?"
And he goes, "Uh-huh."
And she's like, "Oh, hi."
It's the most weird
thing in the world.
And '80s movies are full
of that kind of stuff.
I mean, those kind
of movies don't get--
they haven't lasted so well.
Things like "Porky's."
"Risky Business" is something
that everyone remembers
very fondly as this movie
in which Tom Cruise danced
in his underpants.
But actually, if
you watch it, it's
a movie about how a boy
becomes a pimp, becomes a pimp
and then gets into
Princeton because of it.
Because a Princeton
guy comes to his house
to meet Tom Cruise, who is
now fully a pimp, and probably
sleeps with the hookers
that he keeps in his house,
and then gets him
into Princeton.
It's the weirdest movie
you'll ever see in your life,
I swear to God.
So there's all that, obviously.
And also racism
against black people
is so obvious in '80s movies.
I mean, Eddie
Murphy's first film
was "48 Hours," in which
he's opposite Nick Nolte.
And Eddie Murphy
plays this con who's
let out of prison to
help grizzled cop Nick
Nolte find a criminal ring,
if I remember this correctly.
It was actually it
was actually supposed
to be Richard Pryor who was
supposed to be in the movie,
but he was too
much of a disaster,
so they cast Eddie instead.
Now, Nick Nolte is playing
the traditional grizzled cop.
A bit alcoholic,
has woman problems.
And as part of his
charming grizzledness,
he is incredibly racist.
And he calls Eddie Murphy
things like watermelon, a spear
chucker.
Unbelievably racist terms.
And at no point is this
seen as like, "Oh, maybe we
shouldn't like this guy."
It's seen as part of
his charming, unreformed
grizzledness.
And Eddie Murphy was asked about
this in a couple of interviews.
"Was this not a bit weird
for you to be doing?"
And he's like, "Well, you
know, because my character is
equal with him it makes it OK."
And you're like,
"No, what makes it OK
is that Eddie Murphy is such
a charismatic actor that he
doesn't feel totally
subjugated by it."
He out-acts Nick Nolte
and steals all the scenes.
But when you watch it, you're
like, "This is disgusting.
And why am I supposed
to be cheering
on this grizzled,
old, racist cop who's
being totally racist?"
So there's obviously
tons of that.
And also when you look at
Eddie Murphy's movies, I mean,
I'm sorry to be going
on about Murphy.
It does happen.
He was not allowed to do
very much within, really.
I mean, even when
he was making them.
So you look at "Beverly
Hills Cop," for example,
which was a movie that was
written for a white actor.
Incredibly, it was supposed to
be Mickey Rourke who was in it.
And then it was supposed
to be Sylvester Stallone.
Ugh.
And then to Don Simpson
and Jerry Bruckheimer
has enormous credit,
who are producers,
they did something that
had never been done before,
which is they decided
to cast a black actor
in a white character's
role, and they cast Eddie.
Yet when you're
watching this, it's
very notable that
Eddie Murphy's not
allowed to have sex, really,
at any point in this movie.
He has this white female
friend in Beverly Hills
who works in the art gallery.
I'm sure all you have
seen "Beverly Hills Cop."
You know the girl who
works in the art gallery.
She's got that assistant with
the funny accent, Bronson
Pinchot.
And there are lots of scenes
where this girl's sprawling
on his bed in the hotel room.
They're hanging
out in hotel rooms.
They're old friends.
And clearly, in the
original script,
they were getting
it on, but no way
is this happening in the movie.
No way do you see Eddie
Murphy ever kissing
a white woman in these movies.
So you can how the restrictions
that were on black actors,
definitely.
And this is Eddie Murphy, who
was the most powerful actor
in the '80s.
So stuff like that.
And of course the Ernie
Hudson thing in "Ghostbusters"
is totally weird
and unacceptable.
And I say that as someone who
loves "Ghostbusters" almost
more than life itself.
JON SKEET: Yeah, I remember
watching various films
with my kids.
So we have kids who
are 14, 11, and 11.
It's like, "This
is a great film.
Ignore that bit."
HADLEY FREEMAN:
Ignore that bit, yeah.
JON SKEET: Just ignore how
they're treating women.
That's not how you treat women.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Ignore that
really unfortunate bit.
JON SKEET: But apart
from that, it's lovely.
HADLEY FREEMAN: It's funny.
John Hughes made
quite a few weirdly
racist movies in his
kind of slapstick thing.
Because he came from a
real slapstick tradition.
So his movies, like the National
Lampoon's Vacation movies,
which he wrote, are
so bizarrely racist.
So there's this one scene, I
think it is in the first one,
"National Lampoon's
Vacation," Chevy Chase
is driving his kids
through the inner city.
He lives in the suburbs.
So he gets to the inner
city, which obviously means
a street full of black people.
And their car stops at a
light, I think, at this point,
and loads of black people
just swarm in and start
stealing their hubcaps.
And in all of Hughes' movies--
I love Hughes.
Ferris Bueller is literally my
favorite movie of all time--
the representation
of black people
makes you just want to
throw up on your shoes.
"Weird Science,"
for example, I don't
know how many of you have
seen "Weird Science," that's
also a terrible movie
in lots of ways.
I mean, that's the
only other time
you see black people
in a John Hughes movie.
I'm trying to think
of any others.
And it's when Anthony Michael
Hall goes to a jazz club,
and there are loads
of jazz black people,
all being kind of
creepy and jazz.
And that's it.
So in John Hughes'
world, black people
are either stealing your hubcaps
or basically smoking reefer
and being a bit creepy.
So yeah, lots of bad stuff
but also lots of good stuff.
AUDIENCE: So I'll
ask another question.
[INAUDIBLE] You
mentioned you have
a couple of young children.
Have you given much thought
to what their introduction
to '80s movies is gonna be?
HADLEY FREEMAN: It's
all I think about.
It's really tragic.
So I have two-year-old twins.
So they don't really have
attention span for anything
beyond a two minute "Peppa
Pig" video at the moment.
So they're twin boys as
well, which is obviously
slightly different for me,
although I very much think
that boys and girls should
just watch the same movies.
There shouldn't be
these kinds of limits.
But I do get that
certain things grab
boys' attention quicker than
maybe grab girls' attention.
So for example, my first movie
from that era that I saw was,
I believe, "Ferris
Bueller's Day Off."
Whereas I already know,
from my boyfriend's stuff,
the first '80s movie
they'll probably go see
is going to be "Back to the
Future' or "Indiana Jones."
Those kind of more
actiony things.
Whereas I got to those a
little bit later, and obviously
I loved them.
There was no difference.
There shouldn't be a
difference between what
boys and girls watch.
Let me just stress that.
But I do think they'll probably
enjoy "Back to the Future"
earlier than they might
enjoy "Ferris Bueller"
and "The Breakfast Club."
JON SKEET: It's an important
question about introducing kids
to films, "Star Wars."
Do you start with Episode 4 or
do you start with Episode 1?
HADLEY FREEMAN: I get so
confused with the episode
numbers at this point.
You've got to start
with Episode 4, right?
JON SKEET: Thank you.
You can stay.
HADLEY FREEMAN: I mean,
actually my first Star Wars
was "Return of the Jedi."
I think that might have been the
first movie I saw in a cinema.
It was "Return of the Jedi."
JON SKEET: Jinx.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Oh, really?
JON SKEET: Yeah, absolutely.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Funny.
And I loved it, because I
love the ewoks, obviously.
So I was well down with that.
JON SKEET: And they changed the
ewok music for the rerelease.
HADLEY FREEMAN: I know.
JON SKEET: It was
just horrendous.
HADLEY FREEMAN: It's very
weird when they do that.
I make lists all the
time about '80s movies.
I've already got a
stockpile of DVDs of what
the kids are going to watch.
So yes, "Back to the Future,"
"Indiana Jones," very much so.
"Ferris Bueller,"
which I believe they
will truly love at some point.
And so on and so
forth like that.
"ET," Obviously "ET" might
be the first one even.
JON SKEET: Do you know, I think
my kids got a bit bored by "ET"
but loved "Ferris Bueller,"
loved "Back to the Future."
HADLEY FREEMAN: Do you
know, I was scared by "ET"
when I saw it.
I think I saw it when
I was about seven,
and I just thought
he was disgusting.
And I was like, "Why is this
weird kind of tree trunk living
in this little girl's closet?
It's horrible."
JON SKEET: But watch
Drew Barrymore.
HADLEY FREEMAN: I know, I know.
JON SKEET: Can we talk about
"Ferris Bueller" a bit more?
HADLEY FREEMAN: Please!
JON SKEET: So you talk about how
it's an interesting depiction.
For one thing, I
love your take on it
as a sort of fantasy, which
suddenly explains things,
and it's one of those "Yeah,
why didn't I think of that?"
But it talks a lot about class.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Yes.
JON SKEET: And I find the
whole class and wealth
divides in films
interesting, particularly
because it seems to be an
international difference as
well.
And I see it almost more
in soap operas, actually.
So in the US, there's
"Dallas" and "Dynasty."
HADLEY FREEMAN: Yeah, right.
JON SKEET: In Australia, they're
sort of middle class, "Home
and Away" and "Neighbors."
HADLEY FREEMAN: I mean, one
of them, in "Home and Away,"
I remember when I moved here,
they ran a trailer park.
I can't remember what their
names were in "Home and Away,"
but they're literally
over here "Eastenders."
I couldn't believe
the differences.
JON SKEET: There's now middle
class, upper middle class
in Australia.
And then we have "Eastenders"
and "Coronation Street."
And if you look at a lot of
the UK film industry output,
things like "Brassed
Off," "Billy Elliot,"
tends to be more working class
and will focus on the class
divide more.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Yeah.
JON SKEET: So I
find it interesting
how "Ferris Bueller's Day Off"
focuses is on the class divide
but between upper middle class
and really, really, rich.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Yeah, for sure.
JON SKEET: And that
feels like wealth
as a proxy for
structure versus agency.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Yes.
JON SKEET: Which
I only found out,
learned about as terms
reading "Girls Will Be
Girls" by Emer O'Toole.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Very good.
JON SKEET: Awesome,
awesome book.
Go read.
What films should I
have watched to talk
about structure versus agency?
HADLEY FREEMAN: I mean, to
me, the most obvious film
about class is actually a
slightly earlier John Hughes
film, which is "Pretty
in Pink," which
is very much about working
class kids versus the rich kids.
John Hughes himself
was lower middle class,
and he grew up in an upper
middle class neighborhood
in the suburbs of Illinois.
So he was always very
self-conscious about class
differences.
And in his movie, the rich
kids are always kind of evil,
and the poor kids are noble.
But the rich kids
get everything,
and the poor kids
have to struggle.
And when he made
"Ferris Bueller,"
he kind of recreated that.
So "Pretty in Pink,"
there's a character,
Duckie, played by Jon Cryer,
who is very working class,
sleeps on apparently a
mattress on the floor,
and seems to not
have any parents.
And he is up against
the horrible rich kids
in school, played
by James Spader,
ultimate crush, who is
this kind of awful drugs,
taking obnoxious guy called
"Steff" for some reason.
All characters in John Hughes
movies have really weird names.
One day, I want to
do a dissertion.
I want to go back to school
and do a PhD dissertation
on the names of kids
in John Hughes' movies.
Anyway, so there's Steff.
So anyway, Duckie is unpopular
because basically he's poor.
That's what "Pretty
in Pink" is saying.
And the same for Molly
Ringwald's character, Andy.
She's unpopular
because she's poor.
I mean, she literally
lives on the wrong side
of the train tracks.
They have her living next
to a train, for god's sake.
So when he came to
write "Ferris Bueller,"
he rewrote Duckie
but as a fantasy.
And he got Matthew Broderick to
play the character of Ferris.
And Matthew Broderick and
Jon Cryer as teenagers
look basically identical.
JON SKEET: Particularly
in the parade scene.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Exactly.
I mean, with the coif,
he's basically Duckie.
But he made Ferris Bueller
upper middle class,
and lives in this big house.
And he made him
exactly like Duckie.
He likes weird British bands.
He wears weird two-tone shoes.
He knows about tech.
He's quite annoying,
but everyone loves him.
JON SKEET: Those aren't related,
by the way, knowing about tech
and being annoying.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Read
the room, Freeman!
But they make him
really popular,
and everyone in
the town loves him.
And so it's kind of Duckie/John
Hughes' fantasy of what
he could have been
like, what life
could have been like
if he'd been rich.
And he could have skipped
school and gotten away
with everything.
If he stayed home
from school sick,
there'd be banners in the
sky saying "Get well soon."
All that kind of stuff.
It's a real teenager's
fantasy of popularity.
And for John Hughes, popularity
and wealth were synonymous.
I think it is interesting
when British people see
American movies that show
social class divides,
because British
poverty and America
in poverty in a lot of
ways are really different.
A really interesting
illustration of that for me
was when I went to
see "Blue Valentine"
a few years ago in this
country with some friends.
And "Blue Valentine" starring
Michelle Williams and Ryan
Gosling, I'm sure a lot
of you have seen it,
I mean they're supposed to
be quite poor in that movie.
I mean, that's part
of the movie is,
they're struggling with money.
But they always
have massive cars.
And I didn't even notice
this when I saw it,
but when I came out my best
friend who's British was like,
"If they're so poor, why are
they driving these massive four
by fours?"
And I was like, "You see,
in America, obviously,
there's a whole thing
about American-like--"
basically, I don't even
know what they call it now.
It's leasing cars.
And in American
suburbs, everybody
has these massive cars that they
lease, and they're going poor.
And that's not saying British
poverty and American poverty,
I don't know.
It's not like American
people aren't poor.
British people aren't poor.
It's just a different attitude.
So a lot of times in
these American movies,
I feel like British people
see people with massive cars
and think "Oh, they're
not really poor,"
and actually it's a whole
different kind of weird poverty
system in America.
Anyway, that's a
different thing.
But also the big
houses in these movies,
that's another thing that I
find British people find really
weirded out by, particularly
the suburban houses
in John Hughes' movies.
Like, you look at the
house in "Home Alone."
I mean, the house seems
as big as the White House.
I mean, the house
is freaking massive.
But the truth is,
in the suburbs,
they are probably
very expensive now,
but there are a lot of bigger
houses that don't necessarily
denote massive wealth,
that they would especially
here in the countryside.
I mean, you can get these big
houses in the suburbs things
that don't require you
to be a billionaire.
JON SKEET: Brilliant.
I could chat with you all
day, but unfortunately, we
are running out of time.
Does anyone have one
final question for Hadley?
HADLEY FREEMAN: I've
got to go back and write
a column about Ben Affleck.
So please, by all means,
fill my day with questions
about '80s movies.
Anything's better than Baffleck.
JON SKEET: OK,
well, in that case,
just remains for me to
say thank you so much.
This has been a complete treat.
And all of you who
haven't read the book yet
have a treat in store.
And do book next
week off, because you
will want to just spend the
whole time watching films.
HADLEY FREEMAN: "Say Anything."
Go home and watch
"Say Anything."
I feel like I'm an
evangelical for this.
JON SKEET: It's certainly
going to be on my list.
I spent a happy, very
happy plane journey
having just finished the
book for the second time,
watching, I think,
four of the movies
in here on one plane trip.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Oh, amazing.
JON SKEET: Awesome.
So thank you ever
so much, Hadley.
And yeah, brilliant.
HADLEY FREEMAN: Thank
you for having me.
JON SKEET: We shall look
forward to your next book.
[APPLAUSE]